أنا فقط أجلس هنا أنظر
إلى أطفالك الصغار الثمينين ،
لذا أعلم بالأمس أنك في
حاجة ماسة إلى المساعدة ، لقد
شاركتها مع زميلي ، ألق نظرة على
التفاصيل
المحزنة لما أنت وتلك الفتيات الصغيرات الثلاث
تدوم وقد صدى لدى
الأشخاص الذين تبرعوا حتى الآن بـ 89000
وأردت فقط قراءة بعض
الرسائل التي تركها بعض هؤلاء
الأشخاص لك كيلي ولفتاتك
الصغيرات ، لذلك
قدم شخص واحد 25 دولارًا وقال
عرض أسعار  أفهم النضال ،
ليس لدي الكثير ولكن لدي ما يكفي
لمساعدة شخص آخر يباركك أنت والفتيات الرائعات
ثم أعطى شخص آخر 20
وكتبوا وأقتبسهم ، رأيت قصتك
وأثارت دموعًا في عيني
عندما رأيت  إن تدفق الحب
والدعم على صندوقك جلب المزيد من
الدموع ، بارك الله فيك وعائلتك الجميلة ،
آمل أن ينمو هذا الأمر بشكل كبير بحيث يمكنك شراء
حلمك الأمريكي
، وكان ذلك هو أنك تعرف أشخاصًا
لم يكن لديهم الكثير ثم  شخصا ما
أعطاك ما يقرب من ألفي دولار وقلت
أنا آسف لأنك اضطررت إلى القتال بشدة
للحفاظ على أمان أطفالك ،
فأنت أم لا تصدق ، هذه
أشياء رائعة لسماع
كيلي ماذا تقول لهم
ولآخرين مثلهم  من الذي تواصل
معك ،
أريد فقط أن أخبر الجميع شكرًا
لك ، آسف ، عفواً ،
جزيلاً ، فأنا ما زلت
في حالة إنكار إذا كنت لا تستطيع حقًا أن تخبرني
أن هناك الكثير لتستوعبه
آسف يا فتيات ، إنه أمر مروع حقًا ،
هذه
دموع من الفرح ، صدقني ، أنا أه
لا ، أنا ممتن جدًا لأني
أقدر كل واحد
منكم وأود أن أعتقد بشكل خاص أنني
لا أعرف ما إذا  يمكنني لكن
كيم الشخص الذي تواصل مع عائلتي ،
أنا ممتن جدًا ، نحن ممتنون جدًا
لكم يا رفاق
لأنه لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عما سنفعله ،
وبين عشية وضحاها فقط ،
تواصلت معكم جميعًا
وساعدتم  لا ندعم
كلماتك المشجعة كما لو
أنها أعطتني الكثير من
الأمل
وأنا  أريد فقط أن أتأكد من أنني أبذل قصارى جهدي
لمساعدة الشخص التالي الذي هو في نفس وضعي
وشعرت للتو بأنني محظوظ حقًا
وأشكركم كثيرًا بصراحة يا رفاق ،
أنا آسف بالطبع لا بالطبع يا كيلي
وأم نحن  يجب أن نعلمك فقط أن
Kelly ، gofundme الخاص بك ، ارتفع فقط إلى 97000
بينما كنا نتحدث ،
شكرًا لك ، أنا آسف
لأنني كنت أقول للتو أن gofundme
الآن يبلغ
97000. الشخص الذي كان في 89 قبل دقيقة
نعم  هل هي
نعم 97000.
هذا جنون ، أنا آسف ، هذا مجنون ،
يا إلهي ، لقد قالت للتو إنها 97000
الآن
هذا جنون ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم يا رفاق ،
يا إلهي
، أنت وعائلتك تستحقون ذلك
أنت وعائلتك.  تستحق كل هذا العناء ،
فأنت تستحق ذلك ، فأنت تستحق
تلبية احتياجاتك
ليس فقط بالأمس وليس فقط عدم
وجود دليل بالأمس فقط ، هذا أمر
مجنون بالنسبة لي
مثل هذا المجتمع المجتمعي العظيم ،
يا إلهي ،
هناك الكثير من الدعم وهذا شيء عظيم
شكرا يا رفاق